[Music]
Zero's a is your rose a brand this is
roses and rose a live so oh my gosh we
are about to pop this rose a on a
Tuesday morning can you do the honors
can you open up
I mean touch it hard oh thank you for
being here tell me about why you wanted
to make it rose a and like tell me about
it so yeah I mean I've always loved Rose
a especially I mean I feel like the last
couple years Rose A's become just such a
popular drink because it is so easy to
enjoy no matter what time of day whether
it's 10 o'clock on a Tuesday you know
and it's just one of those things
especially in California it's just a
drink then I personally it was my go to
Cheers
no yeah Cheers what a boss lady
it's amazing you guys should brought it
in an igloo putting for me to keep it
cold it's so good I've never had it
before but you were killing it you're
selling it you're in different
restaurants this is a venture between
you and your boyfriend damn it so how
what does that like to work together and
be in a relationship yeah okay so when
we first started it I remember
specifically like so many people think
like are you sure you want to do that
because you hear about it all the time
like things that just can go kind of
awry when it's whether it's like married
couples working together or whatever but
for us it's actually really fun it's
been challenging at times and we have to
work through things but I think it's
forced us to communicate better it's
forced us to kind of be creative
together and like have this shared kind
of project and shared passion now
together which i think is really cool
how long have you guys been together and
how are things going it's been a year
which is crazy if we're doing really
well it's definitely been I feel bad
because I feel like we did start like in
hindsight I think we started dating like
I wish I would have taken a little bit
more time but it just that's the way it
went like it naturally evolved we had
known each other before I went on The
Bachelor and we're friends and so but I
do feel bad because like I went through
very hard public breakup and I do think
I brought a lot of like emotion into me
and Devon's relationship at the
beginning and so it's definitely been
like a rollercoaster of a ride and you
know like he doesn't
understand all of this stuff and he's
very confused by it especially at first
when all people wanted to ask me about
was then and it was hot he was such a
trooper and so we've been through a lot
together but I think that makes us like
that much stronger
so we're doing really well I love that
how did you kind of get through that
when you say he was such a trooper I
mean did you have to talk him through
and say like stick with me through this
I've got to deal with all this how do
you get through that honestly like I
never had to talk him off the cliff like
he was just always very supportive but
there were times where he was like hey
this is really hard for me like and I
never really stopped and thought about
gosh that must be like I never really
put myself in his shoes at first cuz it
was just kind of like I was just kind of
also in the moment dealing with it all
but now looking back I'm like gosh he
really had to kind of hear a lot of
things that you don't really want to
hear about the person you're here now
like in love with and dating you know so
I mean I think it was just like
communication and just trying to be
understanding of where each other is
coming from but he was always so
supportive of me he really was what is
it that makes you not just that support
but what other qualities make you really
happy with this guy
he is very like I can be a little I can
stress out about little things and try
to like look too much into the future
and plan too much and he's very much
like no like let's just enjoy this
moment take it day by day
he also pushes me like with the rose' I
feel like I have all these ideas but I
never know where to start so I never
actually start and he's the person who's
like no like let's start here we're
gonna make this happen so he really does
like push me to kind of do things that
I've dreamt of or things that I'm
passionate about or want to do and and
not push me in a way that's like
aggressive just really like lightly kind
of kind of like give me that little
nudge that made me I need at times yeah
which is really cool and I've never
really like had someone who does that
for me yeah yeah what was that like for
you because you know like you said you
went through a tough breakup and I know
I mean I just remember sitting like the
criticism you got on social media at
that time what was the key for you to
getting past that was Devin the key for
it or what was it yeah he was like super
yes he helped me a lot I think it was my
friends and my family and
honestly I think it was just not reading
it I just had to take a step back and
for for a while there I just didn't read
anything and I still really don't like
there's there was a lot of stuff out
there that I could have been deep into
like reading and I just fit for me
personally it was better to just not
even look and kind of continue about my
life but yeah he was definitely a key
part in helping me kind of stay grounded
and like not listen to the criticism and
but I mean I still when you hear
something it's really still it sticks
with you so what was the hardest part
about that time was it the criticism
from people what was good tough I think
it was the criticism I think it was like
I was sad about the breakup and I was
going through a lot of changes I was
like moving my life and like trying to
like resettle and get my like footing
underneath me and um and I was and I was
sad and I felt I had like I felt like I
had failed I felt like all these
emotions that you feel on a breakup
right but then it was also on a very
public scale and I did feel like you
know I think everyone always wants there
to be someone at fault or a reason why
or like someone wants to point the
finger and I think because I started
dating Devin so soon after I was kind of
an easy like target for the reason for
the breakup or whatever and so that was
obviously hard but you know breakups are
hard whether you met on The Bachelor or
not like breakups Huck and you know when
you look back I mean I feel like your
life it's kind of crazy we were talking
about bachelor time feels longer because
so many shows happen but really in a
pretty short amount of time you move to
Colorado you move back you don't work as
a flight attendant more now you have
this other job like what have you kind
of learned about yourself as you think
gosh I think I learned that I'm a lot
stronger than I thought I was because
you know growing up I'm so thankful I
had such a steady upbringing my family's
together I literally my parents still
live in the house that I grew up in so I
didn't experience a ton of change and
then all the sudden in such a short
amount of time like you said I moved I'm
a bad guy was engaged I wasn't I'm date
like there was so much change that it
was so overwhelming
I realized that I could can't handle it
and I'm still standing and I feel like
I'm stronger than before so I think it
just taught me that you know you might
be thinking that this is like the
hardest thing and I'm never going to
come out of it but you will and I
definitely learned that during that time
I love that we're gonna wrap up here but
yeah just so many pushes so much love
coming in for you I mean really quick
marry be wants know are you and Devon
living together no no I mean we like
spend so much time together and we live
ten minutes ten minutes down the road
but like I said I've just been through
so much change I think that's definitely
not something I want to rush but we
definitely could at this point I think
it just the timing has to be right so
you're happy but you want to take things
a little bit slower right now yeah yes I
think I think The Bachelor taught me
honestly that I'm just I for me at least
personally I want to take things a
little bit slower this time around and
and not rush anything well so happy to
see you so happy
I really cannot top this rose in a few
guises you know I love my rosiness and
this one is really tough and it's from
Provence which is where all the good
roses my okay she knows everybody makes
sure of course to follow Lauren on
social media if you don't already and
you also have your clothing as well yes
if you want to did yeah so Bell view of
the label fell view is actually the
street I grew up on so that's kind of
where it all stems from but yeah we did
a collection of five pieces just fun to
kind of like test and see what people
liked but honestly more so because I
wanted the clothes that I loved to wear
the summer so I was like oh let's make
some clothes I'll make myself a wine
rack so some clothes
good right go but yeah so it's been
really fun I've been really busy but I
love clothes and I love rose a so it
kind of already has been
[Music]